[Musique]
le mana le marché agricole du nord
atlantique chaque samedi devant le
tombeau lot de sainte marie avec nous
dans ce studio monette thorel président
de solana bonjour bonjour monsieur le
temps bonjour à théo dieter alors
monnaie thorel 18 ans d'existence pour
ce mandat et vous êtes présidente depuis
dix ans quelle est la recette de ce
succès eh bien c'est la fidélité courage
et la ténacité de nos agriculteurs tout
simplement tout simplement sur les
agriculteurs qui sont meetic est issu du
film exactement nous sommes nous sommes
les producteurs nous sommes les vendeurs
nous sommes là que nous sommes le pied
la tête de notre axe de notre
association
comment ça s'est passé autour des bus
alors c'est et pour une fois pour la
première fois de cette marie l'édilité a
eu l'idée de mettre en place ce marché
c'est parti tous les mois et puis
ensuite toutes les semaines voilà elle
nous sommes là 18 ans et c'est pareil
cas fait qu on s'assume teignant
organisation bien particulière aux bêtes
a expliqué moussa et bien alors une
équipe d'agriculteurs dont quelques noms
en tête mais unique d'un culte environ
7,8 ont pris le pari de faire un marché
par semaine au début ils ont fait comme
tous les marchands ils se sont ils
soumis les produits chacun dans son état
les to et puis l'idée a germé de la tête
d'un de nos agriculteurs qui se dit
pourquoi pas mettre les produits en
commun et puis c'est ce qui s'est passé
avec eux tout mutualisé exactement y
compris la caisse tout les produits un
hameau et la caisse ensuite oui et
comment ça se passe personne n'a eu
envie ils peur que avec quelques ce
petit peu plus malin que les autres
ah ben oui mais alors il ya de la
transparence
oui a eu au départ il ya quelques uns
qui ont préféré garder l'ancienne
méthode et son parti mais depuis que je
suis là en tout cas
tous ceux qui sont là ne jure que par la
caisse commune alors c'est le même
rituel
vous nous dites chaque semaine voici ce
qu'on va proposer aux consommateurs
voici le pot commun et puis après on
fait la répartition alors le matin on
l'avait le samedi d'avant nous
planifions
nous planifions donc nous savons qui
amène à croire
nous avons deux trois producteurs honda
chine puisque ses deux produits phares
de la chine les légumes puisque le jeu
nous sommes du nord atlantique doc c'est
là qu'ont fait les mieux lemieux l'est
de la chine et les ignames donc on a
quelques producteurs fruits en légumes
et donc nous savons à peu près après 18
en quelle quantité passe donc ça veut
dire que bon la semaine d'après nous
savons qui est ramenée quoi et ensuite
voilà nous nous arrivons le matin nous
pesons les produits nous allons le
marché puisque nous partons avec nos
étals elle samedi d'après d'avant donc
les prix sont connus à l'avancé vous
savez combien vous vendrez telle ou
telle production pas voilà oui nous à
nous faisons les marchés donc nous
savons un peu
une petite commission qui vérifie les
prix une petite commission qui planifie
une petite commission qui adopteraient
louis c'est la chaussure le 2e prix si
la carie vers les marchés pourquoi vous
négociez totalité boudé le buggy pas une
négociation unis un à un acteur du vent
donc au pas les négociations donc on
sait déjà quel prix et donc du fait
d'avoir un seul interlocuteur nous
pouvons y a pas de négociation possible
déjà la négociation elle est toute faite
parce que les produits sont directs
conso directe ou indirecte du producteur
donc les prix sont déjà vraiment voilà
alors il ya plusieurs questions qu'on va
composer mon et aurel mais la première
si vous êtes là ce n'est pas franchement
par hasard c'est parce qu'il ya quelques
jours nous célébrions les 10 ans de
février 2009 qui a quand même marqué
pour beaucoup de martinique est une
sorte de leur fait une volonté en tout
cas de retour aux sources de de retour à
la production paysanne manger manger aux
canaux est ce que vous l'avez ressenti
ce tournant de février 2009 à me vous
pouvez le quoi après la crise qu'on a eu
en 2008 pour dire que nos produits
ce qu'ils sont et et de la tnt pas bons
est arrivé 2009
et bien voilà nous étions au coeur de
l'action c'est de nous qui étions là
nous avons reçu les clients nous avons
reçu tout le monde et nous avions
l'impression en tout cas que bon tout
passer par nous et aujourd'hui
on se rend compte qu'on a récupéré
quelques quelques personnes qui se
disent voilà le marché était là pour
nous en 2009 et nous sommes restés
fidèles et ils sont là ce qui vient vous
voir ce sont ce sont des gramounes ses
débuts en avait ce public là les grandes
personnes qui fréquentaient c'était plus
des personnes âgées
aujourd'hui on a des familles on a des
familles qui arrivent un petit peu plus
tard au marché mais qui ce qu'ils ont
pris l'habitude de venir au marché comme
aux riches papa momo riches
ggp ou des mois une fin une famille qui
vient tous les matins à partir de 6
heures elles y sont là avec le fils la
fille les lieux les deux parents parce
que vous avez constaté que vous avez un
véritable rôle d'éducateur sur ce que
nous produisons ici en martinique ça
c'est quelque chose qui est que tout le
monde aime bien raconter autour de ce
manas pour dicter acadie anti condition
que la travail qui monnaient tel produit
tassotti équipements des formations
nécessaires
voilà le client est content de nous
rencontrer et de parler avec nous
d'échanger de de nous voir tout
simplement et quelquefois ou moi c'est
voir de savoir que mon a fait commencer
sortie est ce que eux aussi ils peuvent
dahissiho peut être une prochaine petite
cloche de laitue ce qu'on a on a une
adhérente qui fait des petits plombs ils
nous demandent comment comment faire
c'est l'idée c'est de valoriser de
communiquer sur le produit et donc les
les clients qui viennent vraiment c'est
une forme de militantisme je vais dire
il
il souhaite connaître les produits et
parle et qu'on en parle
est ce que le mana est une vraie
alternative à la vente aux grandes
surfaces à la vente via les coopératives
alors moi si j'ai une alternative c'est
bien l'amour est donc cia sept votes en
coopérative qu'il faut parce qu'il faut
quand même livré les ailes
les hôpitaux les quand il ne peut faire
connaître nos produits à nos enfants
et donc cette forme là parce qu'il ya
aussi des agriculteurs qui aiment poggio
et qui n'aiment pas à vendre
ça c'est cette forme là il faut qu'elle
existe et puis il ya celle là où il ya
quelques petits agriculteurs qui sont je
dis petit par la taille parce que ce
sont des personnes qui sont tuées aux 2
3 hectares mais c'est ce sont des
entreprises qui qui n'ont pas plus que
ça de tonnage qui ne ne peuvent pas
produire et manger d'aller dans des
coopératives puisque bon et attendre de
payer de trois mois et donc voilà
l'alternative pour ses habitudes à
pouvoir connaître et à l'heure où nous
disiez que hausse est deux semaines à il
ya une vraie fidélité très très peu
demande pas du tout en sont sortis
est-ce que vous avez des demandes
d'adhésion ah oui on a des jeunes qui
ont déjà adhéré et qui connaît encore
des demandes en attente la wii il y à de
nouvelles personnes qui souhaitent
adhérer maintenance et c'est là notre
force serait ce aussi notre notre point
faible pour par rapport à l'adhésion
puisque c'est la caisse commune donc il
faut complètement adhéré à cette forme
est ce qu'on a voulu couper copier le
banat ailleurs que cette marie oui on a
travaillé un peu avec le lorrain la
ville du haut bas aussi on a travaillé
un peu mais je me dis que c'est
l'encadrement il faut l'encadrement des
élus autour de ces agriculteurs là parce
qu'au départ on a quand même été
accompagnés il faut le dire par la
municipalité de l'époque et donc je
pense que c'est la cad re mans qui fera
que ces personnes-là se prennent en main
pour les agriculteurs tout cas des
tentatives au lou rey et européennes
pourquoi ceux-là peuvent continuer à
fonctionner c'est la même chose c'est la
caisse commune oui c'est la mentalité il
faut vraiment
intégrer l'idée de la mutualité et c'est
un peu ça notre notre credo c'est la
mutualité il faut venir au marché voit
que mon tout le monde s'installe le
matin et les stalles tous les produits
qui compte et c'est celle habitude d un
peu ça qui pêchent en ce moment la toute
dernière question je vous posais mon et
or elle est ce que vous êtes sûrs de la
qualité des produits qui sont exposés
est-ce que je suis sur wii alors je veux
dire que ce sont de vraies entreprises
je vous ai dit que ce sont de vraies
entreprises qui y est qu'ils sont
déclarés et qui sont suivis par la ddaf
donc et l'adaf pas plutôt qu'il ya deux
semaines on m'a appelé pour venir me
contrôler mon podium est produit comme
ça sur le terrain
donc ce sont des entreprises qui sont
déclarés ça et ça c'est pour l'intérêt
du marché
on a intérêt à être bon merci mon être
thorel d'être venu avec nous dans son
caddie ce jeudi matin vous souhaite une
bonne journée et puis encore une bonne
une bonne continuation pour le manas le
marché agricole du nord atlantique dont
vous êtes la présidente depuis dix ans
merci bonne journée mais s'il assure le
temps